what's up BTS army or I'm over here give
a shot but see I don't know about I used
to fail so you can every tear sir me to
him do you Johnna speak the best English
when I'm doing Greg's impression
see I'm going Rodney Dangerfield guys
we're gonna watch this music video BTS
on official MV what did you just cover
our patreon page recently goodness it
was the coma prema manifesto short film
thing she had her patron we do weekly
Q&A Steve show reactions and he does
music video reactions weekly over there
at all so I mentioned after this
reaction what Jon's unboxing something
map of the soul 7 version which version
if you know the colors you already know
but if you don't it's a mystery and for
everyone who pledges $1 at our patreon
page you're gonna enter a raffle where
Jon has bought front-row seats for the
BTS concert happening in LA 10 tickets
he bought available so that's not real I
don't wanna pick up that I'm being
sarcastic oh boy
this is like dark
I haven't heard this song yet my first
time
run
that was art
[Music]
[Music]
but it's so bright outside oh what a
great shot
[Music]
this is that tattoo
[Music]
it's gonna be a Titan
or it's the Maze Runner they
set design in this video oh yeah
location scouting
damn son hooked up now
Wow that Fredro miss Vasquez rocks
[Music]
whoa whoa but it's right the be change
ha ha ha
these guys are so cool
I love this grace up yeah it's for
graphic greats up
[Music]
[Music]
it's like a darren aronofsky short yeah
but he doesn't lead the revolution guys
right drop that ring in the Mount Doom
[Music]
Oh don'tjump jungkook
Wow
what a painting yeah
so we should be dreaming we should
always be got it got it is your evening
cooler that's the point
lyrics interpretation let's talk about
the music video a bit then we can unbox
that thing yeah what do you think what
you thinking what did you think you're
the music video experts I mean this is
really cool this was very different from
the other video I saw which is basically
just them and some backup dancers and
what looked like the LA reservoir
something like that and it was just one
of those things where they shot it with
a bunch of drones so everything looks
awesome but this really ramped up the
sort of cinematic tone obviously I mean
to me it's one of those anthems about
perseverance and stuff and it brings
some of the themes that we've seen
across some of the other songs that have
led up to the new album like the shadow
sides of their place in the world the
self-doubt the struggles the sacrifices
and the ways in which yeah you might not
be at your best but you can still you
know rise beyond that and improve and
you know bring yourself back to the
light and I thought this video just kind
of accentuated that with various
different images of people either dead
knocked down bound you know and then you
know rising up at the end of the video
all the armies back on their feet the
trees grow back there's a sort of
defiance against yeah just the sort of
stresses slings and arrows of the life
they get to live that's kind of what I
took out of the lyrical side now yeah
this took those themes I thought and
turned them into a kind of stream of
consciousness epic battle movie it's
like a little out of place in time it's
a little bit fantasy towards the end I
forgot exactly how the beat change goes
down so I like the little interlude with
the conch shell and I'm like an Avengers
Assemble ya know the same thing a lot of
their songs they seem to use the
metaphor of being on fire as a term of
like passion endurance like you were
talking about perseverance and they
start this video often in the slumps and
I like having some of these metaphors in
terms of running away from the pain
I like the Noah's Arc
symbolism and then breathing life back
in because when they talk about these
sort of internal personal development
stuff a big part of that kind of
lifestyle is not being afraid to rise up
more importantly being not afraid to
start over again and I think you know
like when you look at Noah's Ark is it's
about cleansing restarting and then here
you do get a lot of that backdrop
symbolism sort of hinting at that and
then of course everything is dark and
desolate like at the end of the Lion
King before Simo returns to save this
day and then life coming back in and
also their sense of unity is something
BTS often talks about on their lyrics so
while they're all individuals who are
struggling it's when they all come
together and the themes of water the
beginning of life right there and then
ending again
on fire symbolism was something they
seemed to really capitalize on showing
that they've been reignited I think it's
a really powerful thing and yet visually
I was I was actually surprised by the
first few minutes before the beat change
because the one thing I was thinking in
my head was this is actually very
different because there's not a lot of
you know post-editing kinetic crash
zooms and a weird cropping which is
always really cool it's like they seem
to really capture as much as they could
fluidly in-camera on the first most of
this video yeah and with some visual
effects to add in and then when the beat
change they did full BTS video music
video for men I'm used to see you from
these guys yeah once it goes into badass
once it goes into sicko most yeah yeah I
really appreciate the sound too because
and I said this in the patreon video I
think there's something interesting
about the correlation between the
subject matter you know that general
perseverance idea and then the like
marching band instrumentation that
underlies a lot of the track the
marching band drums the horns you know
and those get a lot more prevalent when
the beach change comes up and even in
the first half of the song I just like
the build you have that little vocal
line that keeps repeating that gives the
song sort of swirling quality tune and I
think like using a music video backdrop
for historical /
purposes shows that this is kind of a
constant throughout time they talk about
these kind of things and they always
have like a variety of different
backdrops that they're using for
symbolic correlations however going to
the past and really honing in on that
sort of soldier self warrior mentality
BTS army at least that's what I take
from it I don't know how much of this is
intentional and how much of this is just
how I'm reading into a recruitment video
for the South Korean army no it is not
no jokes are getting deeper competitive
joking it is cool to see them in in such
a tangible and naturally lit environment
yeah say yeah because there are real
human beings in Rakas hologram I know
and especially like the last music video
if for ego was all greens greens so well
what'd you guys think of this music
video while you're typing that John
start there's no boxing whatever it is
you bought I bought mapped with the soul
set I was at Target
I discovered this existence so I drove
to amoeba and bought yes you want to
click that pen open yeah that way the
red ink gets all over your covers so
this is version there are four versions
of this I was intrigued but I only
bought one because that would be a
little excessive so I figured the third
one might be my favorite I like the
color scheme they all have different
colors on them hold on grabby annoy
where's your Batman knife and mr. Batman
why don't you buy a knife why do I
always get the knives all right so this
is version 3 I liked the colors that
make up the seventh the most you don't
have to talk to me because there look at
them okay we could enter to win sound
check my Wow sound check if you win this
alright let's open this MF up
Oh oh snap oh wow okay you can have the
CD I mean you know it's available for
streaming for you tubing for everything
but let's see what's in the other side
here if you wanna open up this here
poster I think it's a poster who knows
man it could be anything
whoa cool a big white piece of paper
next we've got another uh yes army right
here the last army but the been the
group squad what are they eating you
know various fruits that's their living
room in case you guys didn't know yeah
living room is based on old religious
artists so we got a couple things in
here various sheets of you know paper
letting us know what we just bought our
you show everything in time but I got a
a jungkook card which is great because
aside from our em John Cook is my
favorite so oh you know I just picked
him because he's cute we got this guy
ooh little little not autograph
autographs and you think you can't
afford to buy ten front-row seat tickets
for our patreon from row seat tickets
cost about the cost of like six of these
to go to the back row of the Rose Bowl
performance it's only like 200 bucks I
am gonna put these stickers all over you
the next time I catch you sleeve hmm
then you can buy a ruined s tickets I'll
give you the notes which are all in
Korean
thanks yes this has a nifty little
lyrics book with trans lo not with
translations all right they're all the
English verses are in English but you
know that's cool last but not least in
this off-road boxing experience got this
really nice folded up thing I'm
imagining it's probably a book or a
magazine but that's just my surmising so
it's like a little newspaper here what's
inside the same poster as before but oh
this isn't even like a legit book this
you can take the
heart oh my goodness here don't you have
one we can show them off it's hand them
together you can have all the written
looking here just like a whole photo
shoot you can here I'm just gonna flip
through them so you can see all the
Britt members on the one side all those
portraits oh man that's a lot this was
not designed with unboxings how much are
they paying us to do this sponsor oh you
know free tickets 10 front-row seat show
the Rose Bowl just add some more well
I'm glad you got this job oh there's the
RM side yeah oh my God look at my photo
it's the best photo out there we all
have to look we all having the less so
and he's not even Jesus depending on
what your perspective is of Christ
maybe RM is your own Jesus no in this
one it looks like junk oh yeah they all
know what you're talking about
alright well John close this out guys
what did you think of this unboxing cuz
we already asked about the video which
version of the album did you get did I
mess up by getting Version three leave
it in the comments and as always you can
like and subscribe this video go like
and subscribe BTS not that they need it
and come check us out over on the
patreon I check out music videos every
week and do my best to break them down
and you know make a little commentary
only 25 seconds thanks man better than
before
outro study I know we're going on 35
you